thanks because it's a real pleasure to
be here I I should say right off the bat
that this work was done primarily by my
graduate student Shang GRU who was a
fifth year PhD student at MIT and he
made the slides but all errors are mine
and anything that you don't understand
this is my fault so I like to tell you
about some work that we're doing that is
really a computer architecture based at
least we started out being a computer
architecture group in the context of
this project and worked on a problem of
cache coherence which is a important
problem to build shared memory computers
but it's kind of taken on a life of his
own and so that's why you see software
in the title and we've taken these ideas
and applied them to databases
concurrency control and we have some
some some I guess grand plans going
forward so hopefully you'll be I don't
know a tenth as excited as I am about
this work once I'm done so just a minute
of context I think you folks all know
this Moore's law is is been with us for
half a century if we think of it as the
the printing press for the currency of
performance it allows software designers
or developers to write less and less
efficient software but have it run
faster and faster as generations of
Moore's law keep going
but the fact of the matter is that we
have some issues here with respect to
Moore's law and a lot of people outside
of probably this audience conflate
Moore's law with Dennard scaling which
is something that I just want to point
out I Dennard scaling was what was
exemplified by the frequency of
processors single processors increasing
at a significant rate and then our
scaling as you can see here stopped
around 2005 but Moore's law did not and
Moore's law is first the doubling of
transistors every generation
and in order to actually get performance
architects had to exploit parallelism so
as you can see here a cooperation sea
stopped increasing the flattening over
there and so the number of cores on a
chip started increasing and so you can
get commercial products that have 50 60
I close to a hundred course on them and
as Andy mentioned during the
introduction I there's an issue now
associated with trying to get speed ups
of from these parallel course because
while the sequential algorithm didn't
really care about coordination or
sharing of variables the parallel
decomposition of a sequential algorithm
has to obey a sequential semantics or
whatever semantics that you would like
it to obey and that synchronization and
coordination becomes very difficult and
so it's been a challenge to get the
linear speed ups that you'd like to get
as you've gone from one core to four
cores to eight cores and so on I want to
say a little bit about different kinds
of parallelism that there are in the
world today as a computer architect I
this is the kind of parallelism that is
closest to to my to my field to my
psyche if you will where you have a few
instructions and there's a sequential
semantics associated with these
instructions that the value of D that
you see here in the third instruction
should be computed by the second one and
so there's a dependence associated with
these two values and that you have to
obey and in a sequential program it's
sort of automatically obeyed but if you
try to exploit instruction level
parallelism and try to run these
instructions across different cores or
perhaps even in different functional
units on a given core this waiting
possibly that needs to happen in order
for the correct value of D the new value
a to be used in the computation of G
right so that's an issue oh I should
mention by the way that I'm perfectly
happy to answer questions during the
talk so
if you just raise your hand they'll stop
good why only linear speed-up I mean
there's this thing called Grand
Challenge list we need better than
linear speed-up I do you mean about I
don't know how to give you that I should
say that uh I in in the context of this
talk I want to essentially give you a
solution where you could pretend that
the sequential processor ran you know
five times faster okay so which would be
exactly linear speed-up right I think if
you're allowed to change the algorithm
and you're allowed to to change perhaps
the correctness criteria of the
algorithm or the results that you want
you could certainly go there but the
semantics that I'm focused on in this
talk it really corresponds to as you'll
see as I go along here that mimicking
these computations right so it's a bit
of it's more narrowly focused in the
grand challenge right so there's another
class of parallelism that is also going
to be important for this talk which
comes from the field of databases and in
the field of databases you have
transactions all right transactions are
usually fairly small sets of reads and
writes and perhaps computations which
aren't really shown here and there's
parallelism associated with these
transactions but you do have a
constraint um just like you had a
constraint about the value of D in the
first example you do have a constraint
with these transactions in the sense
that um you have to ensure that these
transactions are atomic and I'll say a
little bit more about that
but you can you can assume for now from
a parallelism standpoint that each of
these squares that you see here these
red squares could be run in arbitrary
order right but you can't split them I
mean these red squares have to be atomic
you can't you can't insert one into the
other and as I said I'll say a little
bit more about that
so that's those are two classes of
parallelism let's go on and look at
higher levels you could imagine in a
multi-core processor that you have
thread level parallelism where you have
different threads running on
from course and if you were multiplying
two matrices and you wanted to get
parallelism then you might do a row
column multiplication to write one
particular element of this product
matrix C and you could run essentially n
square if you had an N by n matrix
threads in parallel if you hadn't of
course and this would this would work
out pretty well in this particular
example but that's thread level
parallelism
there's many operations that are being
performed in this particular case in
this particular algorithm this little
dependency in the computation of the
result even though you will have shared
data it's only being read the two
matrices a and B are only being read
task level parallelism would be you want
to search for an image on google or your
favorite search engine and there's a lot
of data being scanned that could be done
in parallel there's going to be some
sorting that happens at the end of the
data collection which has to be a little
bit serial there's some dependency there
but there's a lot of parallelism here
and then there's user level parallelism
where if all of us were searching for
different images on Google the data
center associated with the particular
searches that we're conducting has to
essentially service all of our requests
and there's a lot of parallelism there
user level parallelism in my group is
called embarrassing parallelism because
this is so much that you don't have to
work really hard to exploit it so I want
to talk now about dependency because
this is fairly fundamental to this talk
and as you can imagine dependency
destroys parallelism and if I tell you
that you have to compute this particular
array and if you notice I've made it
particularly difficult so my compiler
friends would be annoyed with me by
having this indirect addressing
corresponding to the array where I have
a of BI and B of is essentially this
random mapping that you don't really
have control over and you notice that a
of bi depends on a of BI minus one so
this this chain of dependencies and it's
really pretty hard to paralyze this you
could flatten it out but then if you
don't even know what n is
because it's a dynamically assigned
variable that would be difficult to do
and so this is this is painful and so
dependency destroys parallelism um and
you essentially have a situation where
you'd like to devote avoid dependency
and so let me talk a little bit about
different kinds of dependency just like
I talked about different kinds of
parallelism and they're basically four
different kinds if you think about it
from a standpoint of reading and writing
variables and you can imagine what they
are you have reads and writes and you
combine them in different ways if you
have two reads there's really no
dependency so I guess there's maybe only
three kinds of dependency and if you
have two writes then it's actually
something that bears some thought
because you're gonna get a value at the
end of this these two writes and if you
don't care but what this value is
you know I'd be writing 14 followed by
15 and it's okay from a program
correctness standpoint as to the final
result being 14 or 15 then there's no
dependency here right now it turns out
this is kind of a little bit strange
here because usually you just don't
write usually you do an update which
includes the read followed by a right so
in that sense you have reads and writes
being mixed up and they're not these
particular simple examples but if you
just look at write after write
dependence ease semantics decide order
if your semantics are flexible you can
ignore right and for the purposes of
this talk which is going to ignore that
yeah go ahead
correct yeah no a great point I should I
should have said that as as a computer
architect I cannot assume that when I
was reading or writing a particular
memory location and you're absolutely
right it was a single instruction and
single instructions were atomic so my so
you have to take that into account to I
guess it really understand my statement
and so thanks for the question right so
you're absolutely correct that if the if
the write was split up and you have
problems and you're kind of in the
transaction world okay because you want
a de Missa T so the most interesting
kind of dependencies are raw and war
dependencies and as their names indicate
you have read after write I've
the read needs the new value and that's
really the kind of dependency that I've
talked about in the instruction level
parallelism example and in the loop
example right so these are these are
hard if you need the new value you need
the new value you got to wait for
somebody to write it right and another
kind of dependency that is being obeyed
you know in exactly the same way that
the raw dependency has been obeyed in
prior work for the most part but little
or no flexibility is the wor dependency
where you want it read to happen before
the value is updated right so so there's
a I should say by the way that the
reason this is queued out here is that
these are two different reads
potentially in two different threads or
two different streams of computation and
they could be running in parallel on to
two different course alright so those
two reads could happen in parallel and
we're really saying that those two
rights it doesn't really matter whether
they happen in parallel or not but these
two have to have a dependence so while
they may be running on different cores
you got this ordering to worry about and
then the same thing for the for the war
dependency but it turns out we have a
lot of flexibility here and really for
the rest of this talk I'm going to be
telling you how we're going to kind of
basically throw away war dependencies
right and that's going to help us avoid
dependency and run our programs faster
right so that's really the focus so one
last thing that I have stock board is
relate all of this to the notion of time
um we really talked about dependence and
implicitly in all of our conversations
and certainly what I've talked about
here we've talked about physical time I
when I say after you know it means in
physical time right but I there's no
reason why you know time has to be
physical I mean we are talking about
software programs and and virtual the
virtual world and so time could be
logical and some of your folks may have
heard of Lamport clocks there's some
relationship between that and logical
time stamps that we use not exactly the
same but the bottom line is that I could
just decide that my kind host there is
is number one in my book at least for
today and he's he's got logical time
stamp
number one and this gentleman here has
gage has a time stamp number two and I'm
at three here and we just decided on
order that's associated with with
operations um and I the interesting
thing is that I it's not clear and I
will show you that there's many cases
where there's no reason why Cebu sheesh
has to go first even though he had
logical time one in physical time
services could be latched right and and
I could be first okay so this is it
there's a difference and I'm going to
hopefully convince you that this
difference is important and that we can
exploit this difference to make programs
run faster so time is really a
definition of ordering right and so
there's some global order and some
correctness criterion that has to be
satisfied but the actual operations
could be run in different physical times
right and in fact you know if you were
time zones and obviously we have
different notions of time and the East
Coast and the west coast and if you
think of them as ordered simply because
we know it's minus three etc but we
didn't really have to we don't really
have to um so let me give you a concrete
example a really simple example of how
we can do this flipping that I just
mentioned to you and we look at the war
dependence because that's kind of the
one that we're after and in the case of
the war dependence I have two threads
here that correspond to a read and a
write and the war dependence says that
the that the write after read so we want
the right to happen after the read but I
you know there's nothing that's stopping
us in current computers to do the right
before the read and physical time as
long as and make the copy make that
value thirteen as long as it's the local
copy of a in the local processor and and
that's a ten and that reads ten right so
really dirt simple example of how you
don't have to obey physical time
constraints while obeying logical time
constraints and having program semantics
being correct right so keep this in mind
it's gonna get a little bit more
complicated but this is the essence of
of the avoidance of dependency so
physical time different from logical
time
so what is correctness I mean I keep
talking about correctness and I haven't
really defined it well you need to have
a precise definition of correctness if
you want to compare a parallel execution
with the sequential execution and in the
precise sense you want some sort of
ordering definition or a definition with
respect to what the results are going to
be in order to say this parallel
execution was correct and this one was
not correct okay and so they've been
many definitions and typically this
there's a relationship between the
outputs or the ordering like I said from
the parallel to the sequential and so
one of the hardest notions to obey which
is kind of the most stringent notion
that that computer architects deal with
and build parallel processors for is the
notion of sequential consistency and
while our work applies to weaker
consistency models since this is kind of
the highest bar it makes sense for me to
focus on it and so sequential
consistency says that I have two threads
and they have a and B they specified
that a comes before B same thing for the
second thread here for C and D and I
want to have a global memory order and
you can think of a and B as being reads
and writes and you can kind of ignore
the additions and subtractions in the
computation because it's really all
about the memory because that's where
the values reside and that's what you're
going to look at at the end of it and so
these orders that I show you here a B
followed by C D namely running the first
thread followed by the second thread or
the other way around
that's fine and you can also enter leave
so you kind of have this and you have
this and you can do this you can do that
you can do this but you can't do this
right you can't invert it a and B or C
and D and you've inverted a and B here
so that's incorrect okay one other thing
you have to keep in mind is that if you
chose this particular order then if B
was a was a read and C was a write be
absolutely has to get the value that was
written by C okay in the parallel
program right and if you don't do that
then you
get the correct outputs right so that's
that's essentially the two parts of this
right you can reorder inside of a
sequential thread and and once you've
decided the order
you better be obeying the dependencies
but interestingly the dependencies are
different the dependencies are different
corresponding to these different
executions and that's it in terms of if
you want a ten-second spiel for my talk
it's it's this which is we're going to
exploit the degree of freedom associated
with the execution corresponding to the
correct sequentially consistent
executions in order to find the one that
requires the least waiting has the least
dependence and runs the fastest okay we
don't guarantee optimality or anything
like that but we absolutely guarantee
correctness okay and we're gonna use
these ideas in in in in a couple of
different contexts but the first thing
we're going to do is exploit this in in
the context of cache coherence which is
essentially a difficult problem that
corresponds to ensuring that you have
shared memory on a multi-core machine
right it gets more difficult as a number
of course increases so in the the rest
of the talk I'm going to essentially do
three things I'm going to tell you about
how we can solve cache coherence better
under some metric using this idea I'm
gonna show you how you can solve
concurrency control in database systems
better again in some metric using this
idea and that's work done in
collaboration with Andy Pablo who's a
professor at CMU and Daniel Sanchez one
of my colleagues Stanford alum and and
then I'll give you a sense of how things
change at the atomic synchronization
level in terms of load reserved store
conditional and those basic instructions
at the processor level that give you
synchronization and and what our plans
are in terms of taking this in and
building it into systems software
systems
um so multi-core processors and
concurrency control but really the the
meat of this talk so let me talk a
little bit and give you some context on
why we'd like to improve our shared
memory and the efficiency of shared
memory
so the canonical way at least right now
of implementing shared memory is to use
what's called directory based coherence
and directory based coherence
corresponds to if you let's say you had
nine processors here and they each have
caches so the piece of processors and
they each have caches and you have
different colors here associated with
data so each color represents the same
data same cache block and you can see
that this pink data is in a few
different places and you want that to be
local to you because locality is great
from a performance standpoint and if you
want to go further away then it takes
longer so it makes perfect sense to
replicate data if you can keep it close
to you because you can't build large
giant caches that you can access very
easily they take up too much power they
they use up too much area in terms of
the number of ports but what you can do
is of course replicate and cache locally
but then there's a little bit of a
problem that the problem is that this
coordination that may be required and
you're trying to run a sequential
program and you're trying to paralyze it
and run it obeying the sequence of
semantics and so if you ever write to it
then that that that right arm is going
to have to invalidate all of the all of
the copies because there's many copies
you don't want to have incoherence in
the system where you have the same
variable if you will being you know 12
13 14 and 15 at the same time at the
same physical time that's that's
important in the system okay and if you
if if you didn't do this which was when
this middle processor wants to write the
pink data if you did not invalidate all
of the other copies of the data and then
wait for acknowledgments then I take it
from take it from me that you would
violate sequential consistency okay and
you know that factors in textbooks so I
I won't say more including Patterson and
Hennessy since I'm here I should mention
that but the the pain involved here is
associated with either
broadcast of all of these invalidation
signals and the collection of these
acknowledgments and this pain increases
as the number of course increases not
only that I you also have to remember
unless you're willing to broadcast to
all 100 cores in the system and wait for
I don't have it or yes I had it and I
invalidated from 100 cores you do have
to take into account the bookkeeping
cost associated with remembering which
processor had rich copy of data and
that's essentially a directory structure
that's kind of annoying to to keep track
off and and to store because this is in
Hardware so if in fact you went from 64
cores where it's not big a big problem
and so I won't belabor the point in
terms of the overhead involved in this
book eat meaningful information and if
you went to a thousand course you're
talking about that 300 percent overhead
in terms of the bookkeeping versus
useful data completely ridiculous right
so you don't want you don't really want
to do that so we'd like to avoid this
and one way you could avoid it is to use
this notion of alesis which is basically
a library scheme okay and so this is
nothing to do with with our logical time
stamps yet but I'm gonna relate this
geological time stamps in just a minute
but let me just talk about least based
currents and and and libraries so you
can imagine that in order to avoid the
bookkeeping cost
I give data that is valid for a certain
amount of time we'll call it a lease for
a couple of couple of time units
whatever that is to a particular
processor core zero and that processor
during that time can keep loading the
data and then after it expires then you
actually have to renew the data so the
data expires it's invalid in the cache
you have to go get a new copy and you
have to bring it back right so you have
to choose this least properly in at
least based a coherence model if someone
has a copy and someone else wants to
write it what you end up having to do
is you have to wait as these this dotted
line shows for that data to expire and
that waiting is going to be a function
of the length of the lease so it becomes
incredibly important to get the leases
exact you know kind of exactly right
because the leases are too short you
keep renewing and the leases are too
long then you wait on rights okay so
this doesn't actually work work and I've
tried very hard a few years ago to get
this to work and then I couldn't get it
to work what we do in the tardis
protocol is is used logical leases but
before I tell you about tardes let me
tell you the one nice thing about this
lease based protocol the one nice thing
about this leased space protocol that
you might have guessed is that my
bookkeeping information is much less
because I don't need to know who checked
out this book from the library right all
of you could have checked out this book
if your processors or a subset of you
what I need to know is the maximum time
associated with all of your leases it's
just one number and that maximum time
sadly is the time that I have to wait
for in order for someone to write the
data right so I've gone from order n
bookkeeping information to order one
bookkeeping information but what I've
done is it is created another problem
that's associated with the write latency
okay but there was no invalidations and
there were no acknowledgments and there
was no order end information right so
that's why I was pumped up about this
idea a few years ago but I couldn't get
it to work because it's very hard to
choose the leases correctly and as I
mentioned and one repeat myself
so the cool thing here is that using the
notion of logical time we're going to
fix this problem and we're going to
that's where the title you know time
travel what have you comes in we're
gonna actually fix this problem and so
we're going to be back to do not
physical time leases but logical leases
and so we're gonna have a program time
stamp associated with each thread the
loads it's in stores corresponding to
each thread and so there's like multiple
clocks associated with with each
different processor which are keeping
different times so this is
and they may vary they may get closer
together and they may jump ahead etc you
never roll back but you could jump ahead
so the rates of incrementing these
clocks are different and so we're going
to basically have two time stamps the
the two time stamps are and this is
important because this is incredibly
important because every algorithm that
I'm going to talk about from here on out
is dependent on the definition of these
two time stamps and it the first time
stamp is the right time stamp WCS is is
shown here and the second one is the
read time stamp the right time stamp
you can think of it as the version of
the data every time I'd read the excuse
me write the data I'm going to increment
the the right time stamp I at least buy
one because I need a new version of the
data right so if I see two pieces of
data with two different right time
stamps whether the values are the same
or not I I know that they're two
different versions of the data and RTS
is the read time stamp and the semantics
there are simply that the data is valid
when it was written which obviously was
when the write time stamp time started
till the read time stamp value so that's
the least right so it's between WTS and
RTS and so yeah also I'm definitely
going to answer that question but in due
course okay yep so what we going to do
is replace this invalidation just and
you kind of get the sense of that
because we already replaced it with the
with the lease idea but of course that
was done in physical time and we are
going to use this lease idea like I just
showed you with the WTS in the RTS but
we're going to do these leases in in
logical time which as I mentioned is a
concept borrowed from multi version
databases or multi versioning and
databases and so that's essentially the
the picture so I've gotta answer your
question and I'm gonna show you an
execution of the TARDIS protocol on an
example and it's simple example but
it highlights I think the interesting
feature of this protocol and I'm happy
to answer questions along the way but
probably best after well you can ask me
questions anytime through the animation
as well I want to say that the animation
I'm going to show you is in physical
time okay but what actually is happening
in terms of dependencies it not
necessarily in physical time right and
I'll get back to that so what I have
here is simply the set up and I have a
core which has a PT s which is the
program time stamp think of it as the as
a time stamp of the thread that is
running not necessarily the the
processor time stamp P is were a program
not processor and my cache line is going
to in the highest level of cache is
going to have well I'm not showing the
value here but this is essentially
saying that it's a shared value or it's
a modified values there's a couple of
bits there and then it's going to have a
WTS and an RTS which is 0 and 10 in this
case right and so and then I'm just
assuming in this simple example that
each core has a l1 one local cache and
then there's a shared last level cache
and you can call it L 2 that corresponds
to the memory right and so there's only
one there's only one copy of a could be
replicated across multiple cores in
local caches but there's only one copy
of a if that in the shared LLC this at
most one valid copy in the LLC so that's
pretty much it and so this is the
description um one last thing here is
that I want to emphasize that the lease
is between WTS and RTS and let's dive
into this this two core example so
that's our set up I'm going to start
with 0 0 this is the cache it's empty
that's what I got here
all the timestamps values are 0 I don't
really care about the values of the data
itself I mean they're kind of irrelevant
because we're just doing reads and
writes and the semantics has to be
correct regardless of the values on
we're going to run this particular
program and the animation as I mentioned
is going to run in physical time and
it's going to be ordered like you see
here 1 2 3 4 5 right
so let's say let's dive right in so core
zero is going to do a it wants to do the
the instruction one which is a store so
what it does is it goes over and says I
need to store I don't have it in my
cache and I want to store a so I'm going
to go ahead and do that store so I do a
request to the core and it now says I'm
going to give it to you you're going to
modify this because you ask for a store
and this s became m in the cache and now
I've created a new version of the data
and this data was was was given to me if
I'm core zero being an owner of the data
and so the WTS and RTS are one because
it's modified it I'm going to be able to
do anything I wanted this data it's kind
of my private data at this moment in
time because there's only one cord
that's interested in it all right but I
did have to implement that WTS because I
created a new version of the data from
the initial version right so now I want
to do a load B and load B it goes over
here and then it's just a read so I'm
going to now ask I kind of arbitrarily
for a lease of 10 and so that was
completely arbitrary because my pts is
that one
it got incremented I need when I wrote
this I have to increment that pts I am
going to get essentially this data back
so I want to do this load and when I did
this load I asked for a load this is the
same processor core 0 its pts got
incremented to 1 I arbitrarily chose the
least to be 10 and so now I'm going to
get essentially B which is shared and I
didn't write it
so the WTS is still 0 and and it's gonna
be valid till 11 because that's 10 after
my pts okay so that's essentially what
we have here
all right now things get interesting so
far nothing much happened I want to do a
store of B which clearly is stored in
core 0 now but I want to do
store in Corwin okay and now I do a
store request what does time stamp
manager tells me is that the B is
actually in shared form in a different
core and in particular the time stamp
manager knows that the and they may be
multiple cores here the time stamp
manager does know this number eleven as
you can see and if there were multiple
course it would be the max of those
values right but that's not particularly
important but good to know so in a lease
based scheme that was based on physical
time how did I have to go tick tock tick
tock tick tock
you know let's say ten times in order to
get to the point where I can write this
but this is the logical scheme I just
decide that I'm gonna get exclusive
ownership of a new version of the data
there's no invalidation I'm just going
to send back this this cache line in
exclusive form and this core is going to
jump ahead in time and change the value
to whatever it wanted and but set its
time to be twelve and create that WTS to
be twelve and in this case it owns the
data so same as the first example the
RTS would be twelve as well right so so
what you see here is in coherence from a
physical time standpoint but it's
completely ok because it's two disjoint
worlds that aren't really intersecting
in terms of time okay and these versions
are going to be ordered in logical time
so the rest of this is not particularly
interesting but worth going through just
to see what happens in a couple of more
instructions it's not that long so let's
say Corwin wants to do a load and now
load is a and this value was was changed
in core zero so what does what this
entails is a request for a load you do
what's called it right back because this
the timestamp manager knows that the
owner of this data is this particular
data is core zero so so core zero Dow
returns this data and and notice that
the the lease is now something that is
gonna take the RTS and turn into 22 and
you might say hi 22 and the answer is
the pts here at least is always 10
that's our default value the pts here
was 12 and so you want this data to be
stored in your local cache for 10 time
units corresponding to you so and you
may as well update it over here as well
because the maximum value that you that
you get it's fine for this to be 22 this
to be 22 that to be 22 I mean you can
leave this as whatever it was before but
the fact of the matter is that any
operation that writes a is going to have
to jump to 23 now so doesn't really
matter so this is a small optimization
which if you didn't quite get it doesn't
really matter and then finally a load
here corresponds to just reading that
value nothing really changes notice
though that on reads the the timestamp
counter doesn't have to increment okay
so this actually is going to post a
little bit of a problem that I'll get
you a little bit later but we do not
increment on reads and that's actually
the difference between logical
timestamps in our protocol and Lamport
clocks which increment on every
operation and we also jump ahead in time
so that's a little bit different all
right so what exactly happened here I
clearly didn't do any waiting I was just
back and forth back and forth right
there was no latency associated with
waiting for something to happen either
they were obviously a bunch of
operations and then there was no
broadcast even though they were
obviously only two cores here but even
though you had lots of shared copies it
was always kind of a point-to-point
communication all right
those two are important to know so that
the what happened oh so this the the
thing that's interesting here if you
look at what's happening all of the
operations here are happening at pts
equals 1 and all the operations here are
essentially happening at pts equals 12
so if you really think about this while
the animation showed you the physical
time in effect because we are going to
do a logical time order the operations
in core zero all happened before the
operations in core one right in logical
time order
and so the picture here is the following
what you see here is the physical time
order but actually what happened in
terms of the program semantics was what
you see on the right right because this
all happened at logical time zero and
that is in fact correct the load be is
in terms of the the the value that this
load is getting I'm sorry this this load
and that load is right it's not that
these values are different after touring
the be if it was trying to you know load
the value of B or something like that
somehow when you know it is that
particular step the value of B you still
have to be in validation and all that
this is good you know so what you said
actually also happens in in this
particular store so so in this store be
here because this load happened I did
not have to invalidate this copy as well
right and so let's assume that you know
you all of this core zero is replicated
in 20 different cores you know minus one
through whatever and each of those had
loaded the B values in a directory
protocol you would end up having to send
all of those things right so thanks for
bringing that up so that's important I I
do not wait and I I jumped ahead in
order to get a new version of the data I
for the purposes of making this fit on a
slide if we stuck with we stuck with two
cores so so these this is kind of the
contrast right so that's kind of the
important thing here um it is important
to understand that it's not that this is
purely logical time there is a physical
time order associated with these
operations they happened in program
order so if you take a look at the
dependencies then basically what's
happened is the original execution if
you executed it and you assume that you
were using a directory
recall I you would have all these
dependencies that are shown here on the
on the right hand side in in there's
only one dependency that that we have to
worry about which is the red dependency
corresponding to the the raw dependency
and that simply says that the load a it
should get the value corresponding to
the story over here and that's actually
what happens because of the right back
the war dependency I've just shown it in
green because it doesn't require any
waiting it was a dependency of
convenience that's the way we think
about it we decided that we wanted to
write this value and in fact this this
value is going to get written
instantaneously and it's not really a
war dependency because you've created
two two versions of the data and so the
the actual in terms of being a little
bit precise the actual notion of time
here is a combination of physical time
and logical time and in particular you
can see that all the ones happen before
the twelves but notice that the ones
have to be we have to do a tie-break on
the ones and we have to do a tie-break
on the twelve because it's not unique
time stamps are not unique that's the
only subtlety that I want to point out
so if you want a precise definition of a
physiological time which we call
physiological time for ease of
pronunciation it's this physique -
logical is that if the logical time
stamp of X is less than Y then sure I
mean in physiological time it's less but
if they're equal then you have to break
the tie using physical time which is
essentially program order all right um
so what does this all mean I did I
answer your question about where the
time stamps are stored right yeah the
unit is is is is valid sixteen bits and
you just increment oh sorry
Cashman absolutely right I mean that
part doesn't go away right from so um
there's a lot of details just a lot of
bookkeeping but they and there's a
longest proof this is not very
complicated that says that this protocol
will produce a global
under this definition that obey
sequential consistency because I don't
have sequentially consistent memories
right so so it turns out that you have
to do a little bit more if you want to
build this on an x86 machine and you'd
have to do a total store or derp and it
turns out the protocol is if you do have
a protocol for it but but it requires a
little bit more work and I'm happy to
talk to you talk to you about that
offline so let's talk a little bit about
pros and cons I am NOT a big person in
terms of quantifying work in terms of
numbers personally but obviously to
publish papers if you have we need a lot
of numbers in this community but I'll
point you to two papers but I just want
to talk at the qualitative level as to
why this would be interesting to a
computer architect and let me say it
right off the bat that I don't think
it's interesting for small score small
scale systems you know if you really
need to get up to a hundred two hundred
course this would be interesting um
because this is scalable it's scalable
in terms of the bookkeeping cost and
it's scalable because it doesn't require
any invalidation or multicast or
broadcast there's a problem with lease
renew and it turns out I mentioned the
logical lease problem where you could
essentially you have to decide what the
lease is where it's much less of a
problem here we arbitrarily choose a
lease of 10 because we don't have to
wait for leases to expire and number one
when you renew leases if we speculate
that the leases will be renewed and hide
the bandwidth of the data coming back by
essentially saying just tell me if I
could renew the data and renew the lease
which is much smaller amount which is
much smaller amount of data and on top
of that we can we speculate it you hide
the latency so you can have an
out-of-order speculative speculative
processor or an inorder speculative
processor that would hide their renewal
latency and that's what we do in our
experiments the true speculative reads a
timestamp size is an issue it turns out
we can do some time some compression and
get it to be a small fraction of the
cache line size
and there's a little bit of a problem of
it reads not incrementing at the
timestamp so if you ever saw a Doctor
Who episode on time standing still this
is not quite a night quite a research
realization of that but but there is an
issue if you have spinning and you use
spinning to check on a value of a
variable you would never get out of the
loop and so you do have to increment the
time periodically at some rate in order
to avoid the live lock that's associated
with this right so that's kind of the
summary of Tartus right so well I think
we are at the point where you know I'm
done with this I can certainly take off
questions you talked to yeah so this I
mean the question is are those cash
levels private or shared you know are
they are there sharded or private manat
a not a big deal this there's time
stamps that are required for the for the
different levels what we think up we
think about the the time stamps as being
determined simply by the l1 cache or
requested by the l1 cache and those
values would percolate through a through
let's say an intermediate l2 and of
course the timestamp manager for
argument's sake would be in the shared
LLC and that would determine that okay
but I'm happy to talk to you about that
offline if that didn't answer your
question ah that's a great question it
turns out no so if you had 64 bit time
stamps then obviously they won't and you
need to wrap around but it turns out you
don't want 64 bit time stamps because of
the overheads involved so if you would
like to reduce that to 16 bits and you
you have to be careful and so there's a
little bit more that I didn't go over
but it's in the paper
yeah great questions time compression
has to take into account this problem
that you just pointed out so really
quickly I want to give you a sense of
why this type of definition
of time is more broadly applicable not
just in computer architecture but in
distributed systems and so let's talk
about concurrency control and the notion
of sequential consistency translates to
what's called civilize ability in the
database world and it's not exactly
equivalent but for the purposes of this
talk you can think of them as being
equivalent so what's utilizability says
is simply that these transactions have
to be atomic you can order these
transactions in any way but you can't do
that right you can't put one of them in
another you can't kind of break the
atomicity of these transactions right so
it's a very clean model and in fact
transactional programming models are
being used in outside of databases as
well so I'm in the concurrency control
world people have used logical
timestamps and as I mentioned multi
version databases came from the database
world obviously but there's a
centralized allocator that's usually the
bottleneck and you can order all of our
transactions in a particular order and
they don't have to be in the order that
they were they were received you can
choose some arbitrary order and then you
better obey that order in terms of the
commit and so on and so forth but
anything that centralized is usually a
scalability bottleneck and essentially
you have loss of performance as you go
to more and more course when you have
centralized timestamp allocation tip
typically these algorithms assume you
have a synchronized clock and if you had
clocks you you would have to abort
transactions because what happens is the
order that you decided on gets violated
kind of at the end of the commit stage
and when that happens you have to abort
and I'll give you an example of that in
a minute the other problem that we'd
like to solve is that it may be the case
that a particular order may in terms of
logical time stamps a particular
allocation may result in a smooth
execution but a different order might
result in abort
all right and so what we'd like to do is
kind of do this in a lazy fashion we'd
like to do some reordering and we'd like
to do some time traveling if you will
even in this context so here's an
example of that so you have a
transaction
and it's t1 and the timestamp that was
given was 1 which means that this has to
commit and once it commits then you can
start this transaction because that had
time stamp to write um so in this case
you do a read here and you've done
you've done a write the read got the old
value these this is happening and let's
say in physical time and that's cool
you got you got no problems here because
this read happened before the write as
you can see right but if you'd given
this time stamp being too and this time
stamp being 1 you can see that the read
is happening here before this right but
it actually has to happen after it has
to get the value that was written by
this right because this time stamp was
too it's a logical time it just got
arbitrarily ordered so if you chose this
it works in terms of both of them
execute if it shows this then one of
them aborts and you can kind of create
examples where you have a lot of aborts
because you just chose these things
wrong right that's that's a problem so
the key idea that is additional to the
logical time stamp idea in tick-tock
witches are our algorithm for
concurrency control is rather than
acquiring time stamps and determining
viability later is we're just going to
use WTS and RTS
just like we did before for these tuples
corresponding to a and B and so on so
each of those is going to have a WTS and
RTS and we're going to not assign a time
stamp to any of these transactions we're
actually going to have these these WTS
and RTS is for the tuples the the A's
and the B's that you've seen and then
much later in the process we're going to
compute a commit time stamp so we have
to have we have minimum aborts I mean we
might have aborts but we'll try and
minimize that's the basic idea and it it
requires no time stamp allocation
because we're going to do done I make
time stamp assignment so real simple
example and to give you a sense of how
tick-tock works you have as with most
concurrency control algorithms you have
a read phase which is really both the
read and the write phase for the tuples
then you have a validation phase
where you determine whether you can
complete this transaction and compute a
commit timestamp which is the actual
timestamp for the transaction and then
once you've done that assuming you don't
have to abort you go ahead and do the
write that is you update the database
all right that's the classic execution
model we don't change that so you're
going to have these tuples with WTS and
RTS meaning is exactly the same as in
the cache coherence protocol WTS means
that you've written that data at that
time and it's valid from WTS to RTS no
changes there so I'm going to go ahead
and read and write the tuples and
execute the transaction in the read
phase I'm going to compute the commit
timestamp and decide if I need to abort
or not and then I'm going to update the
database so here's a little animation
that hopefully makes things clear kind
of the equivalent of Mike Lawrence
example so what you see up there is you
have two different cores running these
two different transactions potentially
as you see on the right this load and
store associated with this and it come
in really simple transactions and
there's a database that corresponds to
what you see up here that's the database
State and these are the transaction
local states that correspond to these
two transactions and so I'm gonna go
ahead and load a snapshot of tuple a and
I'm gonna get some WTS and RTS it's
pretty straightforward I'm gonna try and
I'm going to do the same thing in for
transaction two in perhaps a different
core now I want to do a store when I do
a store just like in the tardis protocol
I have to now create a new version of
the data I'm gonna have to take that RTS
you know WTS two RTS and I have to jump
ahead to our TS plus one to create the
data all right so that's essentially
what's happened here with respect to
store B right after the original thing
was zero to one knowledge they come yeah
I have two created at a new version at
two right and then I'm going to now load
a snapshot of cube will be a and that's
simply a load so nothing really changes
I go ahead and get the double GS and RTS
for for B in t2 as well right so now
what happens here the I need to compute
now
the commit timestamp associated with t1
because I've done the read phase 41 the
simple thing that I have to do here is
exactly what you should infer from the
cache coroner's protocol whenever I have
a write of a tuple
I need my commit timestamp to be greater
than 4 that write set or for any of
those right tuples I have to be greater
than when that tuple expired I had to be
at RT s plus 1 that's what this line
shows and then for the read set i need
that data to be valid so I need those
the boundary of WT s and RTS to be
within the commit time step right and
and that's it that's that's the
algorithm so I can compute the commit
time stamp over here and notice that I
got a bit of a problem here because I
want the commit timestamp to be 2 and
but the pupil a that I've read expired
at 1:00 but if I could ask for an
extension on tuple a and in this case I
will and if I get that extension then
I've satisfied my property of the RTS
and the WCS right so I've decided that
the commit time stamp for t1 is in fact
a time stamp equals 2
right now the commit time stamp for t2
once I've done the the copy of cube also
sorry I've committed it so now I'm going
to go ahead and copy the tuple from the
right set to the database and I've
computed the commit time stamp
everything is done for transaction t1
and let me go ahead and do the same
thing for transaction t2 this is easy I
only had to read a couple of tuples I
can choose the commit time stamp to be 0
or I could choose it to be 1 I go ahead
and choose it to be to be 0 so notice
that I've now done this later in
physical time and I've gotten a
transaction that has a time stamp that
is less than the transaction I just
committed right the TS equals 2
committed first so same same deal
physical time is not the same as logical
time right all right
so I
bombarded you with a lot of a lot of
information to complete this it's a
similar argument not exactly the same
but a similar argument that this
algorithm would give you a serialize
ability right and if you're willing to
violates utilizability and do things
like snapshot isolation the algorithm
would have to change right and that
gives you a little more of freedom in
terms of in terms of parallelism so I I
will say before I conclude here that we
did implement this algorithm this is
just a piece of software it's a
concurrency control algorithm running
underneath the database and what we find
is that compared to prior art are in
high contention cases our abort rate is
substantially lower and our throughput
is about it you know factor to better um
yeah good you don't have a story for
failures yeah and and that's kind of you
know what's going on out here so at this
moment in time we're assuming a shared
memory system which is 100% reliable and
we don't have a story for failures let
me start with that so going down at the
bottom here and and and finishing up
here and this is I'm not going to go
over it show you anymore this is my last
slide but what we'd like to do is is
actually solve the problem of parallel
logging so it turns out in order to in
order to exploit parallelism and be able
to recover when you're exploiting
parallelism you heard be careful that
that the recovery information that you
need which is is basically what you need
to put out in log is something that
doesn't destroy your parallelism because
if you're waiting to write something in
a log and this complications associated
with writing the log first before you
commit to the database etc etc and so
it's a kind of a fascinating set of
dependencies associated with the
including fault tolerance into into our
scheme now if you're willing to assume
that that recovery is simply restarting
the entire set of transactions and
starting over obviously it's not an
issue but if you want any sort of
checkpoint
which happens at a fine-grain fashion
then you got to be much smarter about it
alright so that's that's that's pretty
much it I hope I gave you a sense of why
this is interesting
going back up here and starting from the
top again it turns out that this notion
of WT s and RTS you know I feel is
something that has to be should be baked
into hardware not just because of cache
coherence but because of other reasons
as well it's because you have annoying
things like livelock in atomic
synchronization instructions like load
reserve and store conditional when you
want to maintain sequence of consistency
that your that verse is ugly head and in
this an elegant way perhaps a
performance doesn't improve but you know
I sleep obviously better at night
because there'd be a clarity of
correctness associated with ensuring
that you have no live lock or or
deadlock in the use of these atomic
synchronization instructions and so what
I'm asking for from computer architects
or chip designers is essentially these
WTS and RTS is for every data item in
the system right I if I that doesn't
happen it's not gonna happen for a while
because chips take a long time to build
etcetera etcetera we're in the mode of
using databases and doing things in the
database world and one thing that I
didn't talk about that I'd like to
briefly mention is because we talked
about cache coherence and having many
local copies of the data and and we're
allowed to do that and we can handle
that in the distributed concurrency
control world where I just showed you or
I didn't show you results I just talked
about results in a shared memory system
corresponding to corresponding to the
concurrency control algorithm but real
database systems are multiple nodes
perhaps far apart with large network
latency and they have sharded databases
or terabytes of data in one and
terabytes of data in another etc etc and
it's been really hard for database
engineers to use caching and and I mean
caching at the at the level of disk to
member right because you have this of
terabytes and you want to
in d ram so it's been really hard for
database engineers to do that because
cache coherence is a difficult problem
basically having data that's less
consistent is a difficult problem while
obeying serializability it these two
algorithms as you can see they have this
underlying basis of physiological time
and they kind of seamlessly integrate
which I don't have time to tell you
about and we only figured this out and
in gory detail a few weeks ago anyway
but we now have an implementation of
distributed tick tock which is
essentially something that runs on you
know a dozen computers with with with
terabytes of disk and does concurrency
control across these across these these
different computers right alright well
hopefully I didn't date you but thank
you for your attention so well you know
I had these other slides that had anyway
it wasn't Jefferson time for okay yeah I
had a slide on the t1000 yeah
scalability dependence on like the ratio
of the you know there's actually in an
insight there and so I just kind of
reverse it it turns out that the rate at
which time stamps increase is exactly
the amount of parallelism okay so so it
turns out what happens here is that when
timestamp don't increase it means that
people are reading data in parallel and
and it's good thing because they're not
waiting that nothing is happening it's
when you have a dependency and and
potentially because of contention in the
case of the the the currents algorithm
is actually true even in the concurrency
control algorithm you go ahead and you
jump ahead in time because you're trying
to avoid dependency and and that's when
the time stamps actually increase in
size okay so if you kind of look at a
look at either of the two algorithms if
you if you look at the rate at which
time stamps increase that the the lower
the rate the the more the parallelism
there
that's at least being exploited not
necessarily by any algorithm but
certainly by this one right and that's
true for as I mentioned in all of the
all of the different projects that we
have going on here so I would say
there's a relationship there but not
quite in the way you said the way I
described it right did that answer your
question or did I confuse you okay so
could you repeat your question I have
ten thousand quarters do I want that
timestamp to be wider so I want the step
to be bigger smaller to get so with the
rollover trick that we have we've run
simulations of the cash Lorenz protocol
on a thousand course with 16-bit
timestamps because I mean this is roll
over faster now it turns out there is if
you went from 16 to 32 which
unfortunately by the way it has that
effect on the l1 cache and increases the
the size of the l1 cache but there is a
performance in fact associated with the
roll over because that roll over has you
know this is a few it isn't some data
that needs to be kept synchronized and
so every time you roll over there's a
bit of a penalty associated with that
right so so it's a bit of a trade-off in
the sense that that you'd like to you
don't increase your l1 size by more than
10% 5% whatever but if you're willing to
pay the cost and do a 20% then it'd be
fine in the software world of
concurrency control is a non-issue
because I mean it's you have these large
cache blocks and it's it's software data
anyway so it really it's much more
critical to keep the timestamps small
when you're paying hardware costs and
SRAM costs for it right right that makes
sense
firstly
and there was a second part to your
question you know that's a function of
the leases you're right in that if I
used at least of a hundred as opposed to
ten then absolutely that you know you'll
jump ahead when you do the rights etc
and that's that's that's that's an issue
so if you don't want the leases to be
again if you had large leases then you
won't have to renew as much this there's
a performance implication there if you
use short leases it's better even though
you might have to renew because when you
actually do the right you don't
invalidate a whole bunch of other data
that exists because you jumped ahead so
far in time right so it so at some level
this is a quantitative question all
right I mean you know I'm fond of saying
especially since I'm hanging out in
California that you know you can use
deep learning to solve that problem as
you can you know any problem any any
problem so what is the store visible
because modern processors have store
buffers too crazy so I I give you the
that simplest version of this so so the
question is when does the store commit
you know and and so that's kind of
actually related to it is somewhat
related to the database world you know
bad you have to go cop you know to
commit that store into the database no
it's possible
absolutely it's possible but in the in
the cash for ins world it turns out that
you you have to be let's say you're
doing TSO and you have a store buffer
right well I mean the store buffer also
has the the WCS and RTS information in
it it absolutely has to have that right
and basically what what happens there is
it's possible that if you read from a
store and you realize that the the what
is in the store buffer is an expired
piece of data it's possible that you
your your clock has gone ahead in time
this store buffer hasn't it hasn't
fleshed out yet right it hasn't been
flushed so this thing is still in
there and it has a WCS and RTS and your
processor clock is is beyond that right
then you better not read from the store
buffer you'd be violating so at that
point you what you have to do is here to
flush the store right so and then you've
got to send it out of the system and
then you have to go back to what you
would so I would say that it's an
invasive modification which is why I
think it's going to take a while to do
the kinds of things that the tardis
protocol requires right that doesn't
mean we can't build it on FPGAs and we
are right but but it's an invasive
modification yeah we'll double it yes
and RTS make it into the memory it's a
great question so it turns out you don't
want to store them in memory because
there's no way I mean where do you put
them you can construct your caches in
such a way that you have them and you
can certainly construct the timestamp
manager but I mean DRAM you know what
are you going to do with that right so
so it turns out you only have one eye we
do a sort of a max thingy where as we
are sending things out to memory we keep
in - it can be taken to account the max
RTS of all of these things that are
getting dumped into memory and then when
stuff comes back if we have to do
something with that right so that's a
little bit of a detail and I think I got
it mostly right but I can certainly
point you to the paper that that tells
you exactly what you need to do when you
evict things to memory and when you pull
things back all right but it's roughly
what I told you right so good question
certainly not a stupid question
you could shove it at it it could be
error correcting code time correcting
code oh yeah I mean there's many things
that you could do in fact you could use
multiple of these it turns out there's a
bit of an issue associated with a single
RTS for all of the data that gets dumped
out so if you use if you had more it
would be better and I guess well in the
context of fault tolerance or a
correction I if you could share those
bits I guess you could save something
you